♪ ♪
>> Dana: IT IS OVER, SORT OF,
FOR NOW.
THE SENATE IS ABOUT TO PASS A
SPENDING BILL TO END THE
SHUTDOWN.
IT.
LEADERS ON BOTH SIDES FINALLY
REACHED A DEAL TO END THE
STALEMATE EARLIER.
IT'S ONLY TEMPORARY.
SHORT-TERM MEASURE TO FUND THE
THAT'S NOT HOW CHUCK SCHUMER
SEES IT.
>> THE REASON THE REPUBLICAN
MAJORITY HAD SUCH DIFFICULTY
FINDING CONSENSUS IS THEY COULD
NEVER GET A FIRM GRIP ON WHAT
THE PRESIDENT OF THEIR PARTY
WANTED TO DO.
THESE DAYS, YOU NEVER KNOW WHO
TO DEAL WITH WHEN IT COMES TO
THE REPUBLICANS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TURNED AWAY FROM
EACH WOULD HAVE AVERTED THE
SHUTDOWN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S UNWILLINGNESS
TO COMPROMISE BECAUSE THE
SHUTDOWN AND BROUGHT US TO THIS
MOMENT.
THE TRUMP SHUTDOWN WILL SOON END
BUT THE WORK MUST GO ON, AND IT
WILL.
>> Dana: WE ARE WORRIED THAT
THE SENATE HAS PASSED A BILL AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP EARLIER SAID HE
IS PLEASED DEMOCRATS HAVE
FINALLY COME TO THEIR SENSES.
>> WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID
CLEARLY WORKED.
THE VOTE JUST CAME IN 81-18.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE MORE IN THE
PRESIDENT'S FAVOR THEN
SENATOR SCHUMER'S FAVOR.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT CHANGED FOR
HIM AND WHAT HE GAINED OTHER
THAN MAYBE NANCY PELOSI TAKING
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OUT TO DINNER
TO CELEBRATE THEIR SHUTDOWN.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT OTHER POSITIVE
THINGS CAME OUT OF IT FOR
DEMOCRATS.
WITH INTEGRATION ON RESOLVE,
HERE'S WHAT THE WHITE HOUSE
SAID.
BECAUSE THAT IS THE PLACE THAT
HAS HELD UP THE DISCUSSION.
DEMOCRATS ARE THE ONES THAT
SHOPPED THIS DISCUSSION DOWN BY
FORMER SENATOR PHIL GRAMM USED
TO SAY DON'T TAKE A HOSTAGE WERE
NOT WILLING TO SHOOT.
WE HAVE ANOTHER THING WE NEED TO
ADDRESS.
>> Greg: WHAT IS ON MY HEAD?
>> Dana: 3 MINUTES BEFORE WE
WALKED IN HERE.
>> Greg: A DOOR OPENED AND HIT
ME IN THE HEAD.
>> Dana: ARE YOU OKAY?
>> Greg: A LITTLE BIT
LIGHT-HEADED.
IT'S PRETTY GOOD.
IT WAS BASICALLY A THREE DAY
WEEKEND FOR THE SHUTDOWN.
IT WASN'T REALLY A SHUTDOWN.
IT WAS LIKE A SUPERMARKET
WEARING ISLANDS CLOSED.
EVERYBODY'S BACK TO BUSINESS.
THE MISTAKE THAT THE DEMOCRATS
MADE WAS TAKING A CERTAIN
SEGMENT OF GREATER SOCIETY, THE
PUTTING THEM IN FRONT OF A LOT
OF OTHER UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
FROM OTHER COUNTRIES COME IN
FRONT OF IMMIGRANTS WAITING IN
LINE, PUTTING THEM IN FRONT OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS WAITING FOR
THEIR BENEFITS, AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THE MILITARY OR EVEN FALLEN
HEROES.
IT WAS A LOSING ARGUMENT FOR
THEM TO ATTACH THIS TO A
SPENDING BILL BECAUSE YOU ARE
PUTTING AMERICAN CITIZENS IN THE
BACKSEAT.
>> Dana: JUAN, IT'S HARD TO
VOTE AGAINST A BILL BECAUSE OF
SMART.
EVERYTHING THEY ADDED WERE
THINGS THAT THE DEMOCRATS LIKED,
IT'S ALMOST HARDER TO KEEP
DACA IN THE SENATE FEBRUARY 8.
>> Juan: IT IS NOT PROMISED.
IT'S A PLEDGE.
WHAT I MEAN BY IT'S NOT A
FOR THE DEMOCRATS WHEN YOU SEE
CHUCK SCHUMER UP THERE SAYING
HAVE REVEALED THAT THE
REPUBLICANS COULD BE VERY HARD
ON THE DREAMERS AND MOST
AMERICANS WANT TO DEAL FOR THE
DREAMERS AND SECONDLY, THE POLLS
HAVE SHOWN MOST REPUBLICANS
WOULD HAVE BEEN BLAMED BUT
SCHUMER, AND I THINK THIS IS
TRUE FOR THE DEMOCRATIC BASE,
CAVED.
HE BASICALLY SAID THIS COULD
LOOK BAD FOR DEMOCRATS IF YOU
WERE TO FOLLOW THE KIND OF SPIN,
WILL GREG WAS SAYING.
IT'S ABOUT THE MILITARY OR IT'S
ABOUT PUTTING THE DREAMERS AHEAD
OF SOMEBODY IN THE GOVERNMENT OR
GOVERNMENT FUNCTIONS FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE GETTING SOCIAL SECURITY,
WHATEVER.
THE PROBLEM FOR SCHUMER AND THE
DEMOCRATS IS THE DREAMERS,
HISPANIC CAUCUS, I THINK A LOT
>> Dana: WE TALK ABOUT THE
REPUBLICAN CIVIL WAR.
THE REPUBLICANS WERE REMARKABLY
UNITED THROUGH THIS PERIOD.
AND THE HEADLINES FOR DEMOCRATS
ESPECIALLY IN THIS RED STATES
WHERE THEY HAVE DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS UP FOR REELECTION, IT
BECAME HARDER FOR THEM TO
SWALLOW A LOT OF THE HEADLINES.
SENATOR SCHUMER SIDED WITH THEM
OVER THE MORE PROGRESSIVE PART
OF HIS PARTY.
>> Jesse: JUAN JUST SAID THE
DEMOCRATS ARE FECKLESS AND
SCHUMER CAVED.
I THINK HE IS THE ONE WHO GOT
HIT IN THE HEAD.
>> Kimberly: THAT WAS A LONG
TIME AGO.
>> Jesse: I COMPLETELY AGREE
WITH BOTH JUAN AND YOU, DANA.
IT WAS THE SCHUMER SURRENDER.
HE MISCALCULATED ON TRUMP'S CORE
VALUES.
WHY WOULD TRUMP BLINK WHEN YOU
ARE PRIORITIZING ILLEGAL ALIENS
OVER THE U.S. MILITARY.
HE WALKED INTO AN AMBUSH OF HIS
NEGOTIATIONS.
I DON'T THINK TRUMP COMES OUT OF
THIS LOOKING BAD AT ALL.
HE CAME AND STOOD ON PRINCIPLE
AND DIDN'T BLINK AND NOW HAS A
STRONGER HAND GOING INTO FUTURE
NEGOTIATIONS.
THE POSITION TRUCK HAS TAKEN HAS
DACA TO THE BORDER WALL FUNDING.
NOW BORDER WALL FUNDING IS ON
THE TABLE AND TRUMP HAS
SUCCESSFULLY LINKED WALL FUNDING
TO THE DACA DEBATE.
TRUMP DOES NOT LOOK GOOD HERE AT
ALL AND THE DEMOCRATS
MISCALCULATED THE POLLS ON THE
ISSUE.
JUST BECAUSE 70% OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE WANT TO PROTECT THE
DREAMERS DOESN'T MEAN THAT'S THE
HIGHEST PRIORITY OF THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
>> Dana: RIGHT.
THE GOVERNMENT.
BEFORE THE SHOW, KIMBERLY, WE
FOUND OUT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
CURRENTLY MEETING WITH
SENATOR DOUG JONES, NEW
SENATOR FROM ALABAMA, AND
SENATOR MANCHIN FROM
WEST VIRGINIA, APPARENTLY THEY
ARE TALKING ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
MAYBE THEY ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
IT OUT.
>> Kimberly: PUTTING THEM IN
THE REASONABLE CATEGORY VERSUS
UPCHUCK WHO IS PROBABLY PUKING
TOGETHER THAT'S VERY GOOD FOR
THE DEMOCRATS.
HOW COULD THEY OBJECT?
IT'S LIKE STRATEGY BUT FORGET
ABOUT THE POLITICS.
THIS IS GOOD FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
KEEPING WITH THE VOTERS, WHAT
PEOPLE WANT.
YOU WANT -- WE ARE A NATION OF
IMMIGRANTS BUT THERE NEEDS TO BE
STRUCTURE AND GUIDELINES.
IMMIGRANTS WHO COME HERE AND OUR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THIS WASN'T
SOMETHING HE WAS GOING TO GIVE
UP ON.
HE WAS TAKING A STAND.
HE HAS TO POLITICALLY AND
BECAUSE IT'S THE RIGHT THING TO
DO TO NOT BACK OFF IN TERMS OF
BORDER SECURITY AND PROTECTION.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WAS
PIVOTAL IN TERMS OF WHAT HE RAN
ON.
BIG PROBLEMS WITH THE BASE FEE
ABANDON THAT.
SAY THIS IS NOT ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP.
YOU SEEM TO THINK THIS IS A WIN
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
LET ME TELL YOU A COUPLE THINGS
OVER THE WEEKEND IN WASHINGTON.
THE WHITE HOUSE ANSWERING
THEY ARE RESPONSIBLE.
THE REASON WE CAN'T ANSWER THE
PHONE.
AND THEN A 30-SECOND AD PUT OUT
REPUBLICANS SAYING DEMOCRATS ARE
COMPLICIT WHENEVER AN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT COMMITS A CRIME.
THE CONVERSATIONS AMONG
POLITICIANS WAS THAT TRUMP
WASN'T INFORMED, NOT INVOLVED.
THAT'S WHY IT CAME DOWN TO
SOMETHING BETWEEN SCHUMER AND
McCONNELL.
I DON'T THINK, BY THE WAY, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE LOST TRACK
OF THE FACT THAT REPUBLICANS
CONTROL HOUSE, SIGNAGE, AND
WHITE HOUSE AND HAD NOT PASSED A
BUDGET AND STILL DON'T HAVE A
BUDGET RIGHT NOW.
EVEN THOUGH WE KICKED THE CAN
SOME KIND OF DEAL AND GUESS WHO
IS GOING TO REALLY WIND UP IN
TERMS OF BURDEN ON THE
SHOULDERS?
FEBRUARY 8, IT'S GOT TO GO TO
THE HOUSE.
WHAT DOES PAUL RYAN SAY TO ALL
OF HIS FREEDOM CAUCUS GUYS?
IF THEY DON'T DO IT, WHAT DOES
THAT LOOK LIKE FOR REPUBLICANS?
>> Dana: I ASKED DAVID HOPPE
THAT.
HE SAID HE THINKS THE SPEAKERS
PRETTY HAPPY WITH HOW THINGS
TURNED OUT TODAY AND HE'S NOT
CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS HAVING.
LISTEN TO WHAT MITCH MCCONNELL
SAID EARLIER.
>> I THINK IF WE'VE LEARNED
ANYTHING DURING THIS PROCESS IS
THAT A STRATEGY TO SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT OVER THE ISSUE OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS SOMETHING
SO I'M GLAD WE'VE GOTTEN PAST
THAT WE HAVE A CHANCE NOW TO GET
BACK TO WORK.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS AS
MOST PEOPLE DIDN'T PAY ATTENTION
THAT WE ARE GOING TO GET TO
LATER.
BUT ALSO BECAUSE THE SHUTDOWN
LATER DAYS.
THEY CUSHIONED IT SO MUCH, IT'S
LIKE A LITTLE SHUTDOWN.
>> Greg: THESE SHUTDOWNS, HOW
MANY OF WE TALKED ABOUT?
THEY KNOW GOVERNMENT IS LIKE A
ROMANTIC COMEDY.
THE ENDING IS VERY PREDICTABLE.
I ALWAYS WONDER IF THERE'S A
SOLUTION FOR THIS, YOU KNOW,
LIKE WHY DO -- WHY DOES THIS
HAPPEN?
IT'S NOT A SECRET BALLOT.
PEOPLE CAVED TO PEER PRESSURE OF
THEIR OWN PARTY.
I AM CERTAIN A LOT OF THOSE
DEMOCRATS WOULD'VE BEEN HAPPY TO
IF YOU HAD A BLIND VOTE ON THESE
SITUATIONS, WOULD THERE BE
BETTER ACTION BECAUSE THERE IS
LESS IMPACT FROM PEER PRESSURE
BUT ON THE OTHER HAND WOULD BE
LESS TRANSPARENT TO THE VOTER IN
THE VOTER WOULD NEVER KNOW.
IN THESE SITUATIONS, YOU HAVE TO
WONDER.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF THEY COULD
VOTE EXACTLY HOW THEY FELT.
IF THEY VOTED EXACTLY HOW THEY
FELT.
>> Jesse: THIS WAS DIFFERENT
BECAUSE THE MEDIA COULDN'T SAVE
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY FROM THE
BAD PRESS FOR SHUTDOWN AND THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME REPUBLICANS
HAVEN'T BEEN FULLY BLAMED FOR A
SHUTDOWN.
TWO FIRSTS AND HOPEFULLY WE
DON'T DO THIS BRINKMANSHIP AGAIN
DON'T DO THIS BRINKMANSHIP AGAI
AGAIN.
>> Juan: IT'S COMING BIG.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY WAY TO
GET AWAY FROM IT.
REMEMBER, YOU LOOK AT THE
DEMOCRATS WHO DID NOT VOTE TO
BAIL EVERYTHING OUT.
GUESS WHO THEY ARE?
THE ONES LIKELY RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT.
KAMALA HARRIS, CORY BOOKER.
IT >> Jesse: ALL OF THE SMART
ONES FROM RED STATES THAT TRUMP
WON.
>> Jesse: THEY DIDN'T VOTE FOR
IT ON FRIDAY.
>> Dana: ONE OF MY FAVORITE
THINGS ABOUT "THE FIVE,"
KIMBERLY IS THE PRONUNCIATION
POLICE.
EARLIER, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
CAUGHT IT.
THE SCHUMER SURRENDER WAS